Tucker Carlson had good ratings but was
a huge legal risk for Fox and remember
Fox is unique as a Cable News Network in
that it Garners the vast majority of its
revenues from fees that any of us who
have cable pay
even though I don't watch Fox I have
cable so I can watch the sports and
things like that and um a couple bucks I
guess somewhere between two and four
dollars of my cable subscription goes to
Fox News even though I don't watch Fox
News that makes Fox different than many
of these other channels in that the
other channels disproportionately rely
on ad Revenue so the the issue with
Tucker was not an issue of audience the
issue was that he was a huge legal risk
and so what fox decided to do is to fire
Tucker Carlson